le chef libéral est avec nous on s'en
remet sur trudeau au soir alors monsieur
trudeau la campagne s'achève et pour
essayer de sauver votre gouvernement
vous brandissez la menace d'un retour
des conservateurs et de l'austérité
parce que c'est pas un peu désespérée
quand même au contraire c'est le choix
auquel les gens font face dans ces
élections
ou bien on continue avec un gouvernement
qui lutte contre les changements
climatiques et qui a investi dans nos
communautés dans les femmes un ami qui
défend les droits des femmes des
communautés lgbt ou bien on retourne à
un gouvernement conservateur du style de
monsieur harper qui propose les coupeurs
et l'austérité et miser sur la peur est
ce que c'est la bonne stratégie ce pôle
a peur c'est le contraste qui existe
c'est le choix auquel les gens sont sont
confrontés est-ce qu'on veut continuer
avec un gouvernement qui est en train de
livrer sur les valeurs partagées que
nous avons en tant que québécois ou
est-ce qu'on retourne en arrière si
tellement un contraste avec la campagne
que vous avez menées en 2015 en fait
vous misé beaucoup sur l'espoir
l'enthousiasmé le cours de
responsabilité personnelle dans dans la
perte de confiance parce que les
canadiens les québécois ont perdu
confiance en votre l'attendait le
contraste était très très présent en
2015 entraîneur nommé monsieur harper
qui coupait aux cultures qui faisait
rien sur l'environnement on a été très
très dure en matière de contraste entre
les politiques que nous proposions et
les politiques monsieur harper avait
proposé pendant dix ans des élections
c'est toujours un choix un choix de quel
gouvernement va nous amener dans quelle
direction et on est en train d'en parler
parce qu'il ya des conséquences si on se
réveille de
2 on atteint avec un gouvernement qui
recule en arrière sur les droits des
femmes recul en arrière dans sur la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
arrête d'investir dans nos communautés
dans nos familles pour faire l'austérité
des coupures
c'est un vrai choix et les gens doivent
être conscients de ce qui les attendait
beaucoup de la mais monsieur ford avait
beaucoup promis mais ce chiffre plutôt
que de parler un peu de ce pourquoi on
voterait pour vous si je vous demandais
si personnellement est ce que vous
prenez une certaine part de
responsabilité dans le désenchantement
qu'on sent beaucoup sur le terrain
envers votre leadership envers votre
plus que l'envers votre parti en fait en
fait envers votre leadership
on ne veut on est dans un contexte où il
ya beaucoup de d'anxiété par rapport à
l'avenir les gens sont inquiets pour
leurs emplois des emplois de leurs
enfants et sont inquiets par rapport aux
changements climatiques et je suis en
train de parler du fait que on n'a plus
fait que n'importe quel gouvernement
dans l'histoire du pays pour lutter
contre les changements climatiques
mais on reconnaît qu'il reste beaucoup à
faire on reconnaît qu' on a pu sortir
900 mille personnes de la pauvreté dont
trois cent mille enfants
on a investi dans nos aînés mais il
reste beaucoup à faire et les gens sont
impatients je les comprends mais si ce
choix est ce qu'on continue d'investir
ou est-ce qu'on retourne vers des
coupures
je pensais à vos vacances chez l'aga
khan je pensais à votre voyage en inde à
ces choses-là snc lavalin la gestion de
cette crise et je me disais quand même
ça à miner un peu votre crédibilité
certains disent même que c'est un peu un
leader un référendum sur votre
leadership son élection c'est toujours
un choix et j'ai jamais prétendu dec
n'est parfait mais je pense que les gens
savent que les valeurs et la proche que
j'ai d'investir de bâtir une société
plus forte de défendre les droits de
tout le monde
ils peuvent toujours compter sur sa et
le choix auquel les gens font face met
en contraste
deux visions extrêmement différentes de
l'avenir du pays et où j'ai confiance du
confiance dans les québécois j'ai
confiance dans tous les canadiens qu'on
va choisir de continuer d'avancer
vous avez lancé un appel aux québécois
mais avez-vous
mal lui l'électorat québécois parce que
quand même depuis l'élection de françois
legault
il ya beaucoup de choses qui ont changé
le nationalisme des questions
identitaires ont pris beaucoup de place
et là c'est le bloc québécois qui en
profitent avez vous mal lui ai d'abord
au travail très bien avec le
gouvernement de françois legault sur les
infrastructures même sur l'immigration
sur les préoccupations que les québécois
en par rapport à leur avenir et on a pu
livrer un très bon taux de chômage en
travaillant ensemble avec les différents
gouvernements du québec et la croissance
économique qui fonctionne je comprends
aussi que liautaud jours/7 cet appel à
la fierté québécoise et je comprends
l'intérêt du bloc comme option mais en
même temps je sais que la fierté
québécoise la fierté de nos valeurs qui
sont partagés le bloc n'a pas le
monopole de cette fierté là elle
s'exprime bien au gouvernement et si ça
le choix que les québécois ont fait en
2015 pour avoir un gouvernement avec une
approche différente de monsieur un peu
inquiet lutter contre les changements
climatiques
avez-vous fait preuve d'ouverture
cependant envers les demandes de
françois legault ya eu dix demandes très
clair au début de cette campagne n'a pas
senti beaucoup de sensibilité avait pas
eu beaucoup de sensibilité à ce sujet la
pause dans la loi 21 sur l'immigration
sur la déclaration de revenus
unique sur la loi 101 je suis toujours
là pour défendre la loi 101
on comprend on comprend à quel point les
québécois s'attendent pas à ce que le
gouvernement du québec et le
gouvernement national fédéral soit
toujours alignés ils s'attendent à ce
qu'on travaille ensemble sur les enjeux
qui préoccupent les gens et on a pu
démontrer un un travail sur les
changements climatiques quand il y avait
des premiers ministres conservateurs
comme comme john kani comme d'autres qui
voulaient rien faire pour bloquer un
plan en canadiens les québécois sont là
mais c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin de
québécois au gouvernement pour continuer
à mener la charge dans l'action pour
vivre nos valeurs et non seulement est
présent pour pour pour parler nos
valeurs mais de les actionner
est-ce que c'est pas la loi votre
position sur la loi 21 justement qui a
plombé votre campagne au québec parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de québécois qui n'ont
pas accepté que
vous vouliez contester ou que vous
disiez que vous allez peut-être
contester une loi qui est appuyée par
une grande majorité des micros ne pense
que les québécois aient tous les
canadiennes d'abord connaissent très
bien les positions sur la défense des
droits
j'ai toujours défendre les droits des
femmes les droits des minorités les
droits des communautés lgbt les droits
des francophones hors québec
je serai toujours et je trouve pas que
c'est assez responsables pour un
gouvernement fédéral de fermer la porte
à toute éventuelle contestation d'une
loi mais je respecte absolument que ça
se passe dans les tribunaux au québec et
je vais pas intervenir pour l'instant et
je réserve l'instant d'aucun faut
choquer les québécois et surtout qu'en
français vous avez dit pour l'instant en
anglais vous avez été presque jusqu'à
vous vantez que vous étiez le seul chef
de parti à penser peut-être arriver
toujours j'ai toujours été très très
clair moi la défense des droits
fondamentaux
j'y serai toujours au rendez-vous et et
je ne peux pas fermer la porte à ça mais
je respecte absolument que ça se passe
devant les tribunaux si une conversation
entre québécois et on regarde ça
attentivement mais on va passer gérer et
ça va finir devant la cour suprême
on verra bien peut-être alors sur votre
votre position sur l'environnement est
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
c'était très important surtout huntsman
tonnes par exemple est-ce qu'on
comprenait la frustration des gens qui
comprennent pas que vous le grand
défenseur de l'environnement vous ayez
acheté un pipeline
c'est quelque chose que
jusqu'aujourd'hui mais même tout votre
bilan en environnement je pense que les
québécois comprennent très bien que
cette transition vers une société qui
n'est pas dépendante du pétrole ça se
passe pas du jour au lendemain on a
encore besoin de l'essence pour
l'instant on a besoin de pouvoir
financer cette transition et c'est pour
ça que tous les profits de cet oléoduc
qui accèdent à de nouveaux marchés qui
va ramener plus de profils vont aller
vers la transition verte vers la lutte
contre les changements climatiques parce
qu'il faut savoir financer cette
transition et c'est quelque chose auquel
on s'est engagée nous on a aussi protégé
plus de zones maritimes et plus de
notaire que n'importe quel au
gouvernement on est en train de bannir
les places y accusait
inique vous êtes en train de fermer les
centrales au charbon on est en train
d'en faire plus que n'importe quel autre
gouvernement et on va continuer parce
que c'est pas un peu piégé là dedans
parce qu'à force de vouloir défendre et
l'économie et l'environnement
le message est un peu brouillée parce
que pour les conservateurs s'est pas
beaucoup plus et pas beaucoup plus
simple de pouvoir dire on va juste
annulé la taxe carbone
et puis on va remettre l'argent dans vos
pages c'est vrai c'est très simple de
pouvoir choisir un côté ou l'autre on
est pour l'environnement est pas
intéressé à l'économie on est pour
l'économie pas intéressé par la
protection de l'environnement
mais c'est pas ça la réalité plis
québécois et les canadiens ne savait
s'il est compatible vraiment il faut que
ça soit compatible on peut pas bâtir une
économie forte sans protéger en même
temps l'environnement et pour pouvoir
protéger l'environnement écrit cette
nouvelle société cette nouvelle façon de
faire les choses ça prend les ressources
pour investir
je suis extraire ce que vous allez pas
augmenter la production de pétrole des
ghanéens sables bitumeux ça fait
justement partie de notre cadre par
canadien une limite absolue sur les
émissions des sables bitumineux
ça fait partie et c'est pour ça qu'on
sait très bien qu'on va pouvoir
atteindre nos cibles en 2030 même les
dépasser pour arriver au net zéro en
c'est un engagement très ambitieux mais
c'est ce que les circonstances exigent
c'est ce que les jeunes avec qui j'ai
marché 500 milles dans les rues de
montréal exige de l'action concrète et
je sais que les québécois veulent faire
partie d'un gouvernement qui agit et pas
d'une opposition qui essayent de
convaincre des conservateurs d'agir
parce qu'on a vu ce monsieur un peu et
ça fonctionne pas mais ça va augmenter
quand même la production de pétrole des
sables bitumineux valait pas où ça va
aller diminués mentez avait diminué le
transport par rail qui a augmenté de
façon fulminante depuis deux trois ans
parce que justement on est à capacités
en termes de d'oléoducs donc si on veut
moins de pétrole par rail un oléoduc
moderne fait de la bonne façon avec les
appuis
du plus de communautés possible c'est
une façon de pouvoir financer cette
transition vers un monde meilleur vers
une énergie plus verte
si on parle de politique étrangère
monsieur tout doux quand il est arrivé
en 2015 avait dit le canada est de
retour en force sur la scène
internationale mais depuis on l'a vu que
les relations avec les grandes
puissances comme l'inde comme la russie
comme la chine se sont détériorées notre
notre relation avec les états unis il va
pas tellement bien non plus pas très
facile l'épicerie d'accord elle est pas
facile avec les sens où les succès du
canada sur la scène internationale de
renégocier l'alena de protéger la
gestion de l'offre de protéger notre
accès à notre plus grand partenaire un
moment de déprime visibilité et de
protectionnisme américain
c'est une grande victoire pour le canada
est ce aussi parce qu'on a de bonnes
relations
même avec le président 30 j'ai pas
toujours facile comme vous le dites mais
on a su protéger nos intérêts en restant
unis là dessus sauf quelques
conservateurs et le npd qui veulent
mettre de côté d'accord aussi que de
protéger cet accès aux marchés c'est
important et honnêtement vous me dites
que quand ça va mal avec l'arabie
saoudite ou ou la chine la russie
jusqu'au grade relation pratiquement
maintenant au contraire on note tout à
fait des relations mais on est en train
de défendre haut et fort nos valeurs et
nos intérêts et surtout de protéger ces
deux canadiens qui ont été détenues de
façon arbitraire et en plus on a pu
accueillir accumulé énormément d'allier
à travers le monde qui ont parlé
directement aux chinois de leur
désaccord de ce qu'ils ont fait par
rapport à la situation des canadiens
donc on a une présence très forte sur
l'environnement dans le cadre du g7 du
g20 à l'international avec nos alliés
mais oui on va toujours être très ferme
pour défendre nos valeurs qu'on des pays
comme la russie comme l'arabie saoudite
comme la chine qui ne partagent pas
notre vision et notre défense des droits
humains cndh a obtenu l'appui de barack
obama est ce que c'est vous est-ce que
c'est quelqu'un de votre entourage qui
lui rappelait pour lui
hier capitale vous aurez besoin de son
être creteil personne qui dit à barack
obama qu est ce qui devrait faire ou pas
faire j'ai été très touché de pouvoir
d'avoir travaillé avec lui sur des
grands enjeux de pouvoir j'espère
continuer ce travail progresser ce qu'on
fait dans le monde depuis plusieurs
années et je reconnais à quel point
c'est bien d'avoir son appui ça ne l'a
contacté de votre entourage c'est lui
qui décide de d'appui ou de ne pas
appuyer quelqu'un en terminant monsieur
trudeau si le 21 parce que si on se
dirige vers un gouvernement minoritaire
là c'est de plus en plus probable et
même très minoritaire moi je prends rien
pour acquis
tout est a décidé le 21 et j'ai encore
énormément confiance dans le choix que
veut faire les québécois les canadiens
de choisir de continuer d'avancer parce
que c'est ça le choix auquel les gens
font face et j'ai énormément confiance
aux gens mais si un parti obtient moins
de sièges
est ce que pour vous pour être légitime
politiquement qu'il reste au pouvoir ce
sujet des questions pour des académiques
c'est des questions pour des experts
on va regarder ça et là c'est vous aussi
c'est dans la réalité c'est très
probable d'ici lundi
on va passer notre temps à aller
chercher des appuis les canadiens pour
continuer de lutter contre les
changements climatiques pour continuer
d'investir dans les gens et je l' ai
entendu des québécois de partout québec
qui veulent plus être dans l'opposition
qui valait dans l'action c'est comme ça
qu'on a pu arrêter monsieur reprend 2015
avec des québécois fort qui ont choisi
de porter leur valeur au gouvernement et
ce ne sont qu ils ont besoin de savoir
monsieur trudeau quelles sont vos
intentions si vous obtenez moins de
sièges que les conservateurs
est-ce que vous pourrez vous a cru vous
accrocher au pouvoir maintenant il ya
deux sièges de différence les gens on
s'engage pas dans des hypothétiques on
s'engage dans le choix que les gens vont
faire est ce qu'on continue d'appuyer un
gouvernement progressiste ou est ce
qu'on choisit une opposition progressive
c'est l'un ou l'autre et j'ai bien hâte
de voir et j'ai confiance dans ce que
les canadiens vont choisir
alors il reste plus que quelques jours
quelques heures de campagne au revoir
aux travailleurs
je remercie d'être venu nous voir parce
que je sais que vous n'êtes pas mal
occupé merci monsieur tu nous dire si mu